marriage is not about romance that's one
of the major things that people don't
understand marriage is a contract
between two people to do something it's
not generally about romance
before it became this i would romance
this fantasy this fantasy it was about
the coming together of two families
right for a specific reason
right and the two people would marry and
they would basically they would
they would become a conglomerate now do
you know what i mean it's not about it's
not about it's not about love and that's
that's what i think people get wrong and
because when you think about it you're
going to be with someone let's say i get
married you know let's say let's say we
get married at 30 right well me and you
okay
let's say we get let's say
um me and somebody get married at 30.
i'm gonna live to probably be 80 90.
that's 50 60 years like are you really
going to love them all 50 60 years like
there were times when my parents didn't
get along but i'm glad that they stayed
together because
i would hate to do two christmases and i
would hate to like have that all split
up
love is not based on just feeling it's
principle it's a choice it's a choice
it's a verb
as long as that's part of it it makes it
easy it's like having medicine that's
got sugar in it some of it is bitter but
the sweet one is easier to go down is
emotions are fickle love is a commitment
it's not just about the feeling so when
you're going to get married it's love
not a feeling yeah it's part that's part
of it that's part of it but that's only
a small part of it it's it's a
combination of things it's like it's a
paradox are you saying this duty yeah
that's part of it too yeah but obviously
the you have the feeling duty principle
long-suffering sacrifice these are all
parts of it but people only want to take
the parts that they like that's the
problem i need to ask that doesn't mean
the parents didn't love each other
because they had arguments yeah no i
know that's just that's what i'm saying
but i saw a lot of like i had friends
parents that also argued growing up
and they ended up getting a divorce and
i see them like 10 20 years down the
line and they regret it
because it was it would have been better
for the kids
and then like i mean you put
um i just looked up this stat but a kid
is 10 times more likely to be a victim
of sexual sexually abused than children
that live with both biological parents
because if you're bringing in like
random men yeah you just never know
yeah that's one of the reasons why i got
within my first and mother
imagine stuff like that where would you
be what what that's what i got with my
first son's mother because of things
like that what you're talking about
what bring in different men in
you've had two children already
and this year alone they've seen three
other men
i said this is not the kind of
person i would sit down with i don't
envision a future of you right yes i
mean this is a casual thing and then
you're trying to force commitment i said
i can rebuild i said do you think she
was looking for a step dad for the
children yeah of course of course well
as soon as she saw that um i'd done a
bit of writing i worked and i had my
even that was shared housing and i just
drove a golf mark free old old jalopy
but she saw the bases like how long ago
was this golf mark iii yeah you have
2005 oh i was going to say don't work
yeah so they're carrying on she's
thinking oh well you know his parents
are married still so maybe and that she
said to be fair i told her which i was
silly i told her that yeah the person i
have children i want to stay down with
so who told me to say that within a few
weeks of sleeping with her so mean how
long did it take her to get pregnant six
weeks six weeks
pre-meditated yeah cool spring it sounds
like my second baby one's broken what
she's used to tell me that it takes two
to ten dollars
how many mums have you got i've got two
kids bro two baby moms
what are you what are you doing
well the first one was
i was in a relationship with a girl
okay and
we had the kid
and
she left me
the second one i didn't even want do you
like
in fact her mom told her to get rid of
her other like problem before
[Music]
her other problem what do you mean she
took
her mom told her to get rid of her
problem before that she had with another
guy
when i came her mom told her no keep
that one that one
[Laughter]
was either was either kid planned
uh no did you did you take any
precautions
yeah of course okay what like you're
wearing condoms
[Laughter]
for me to have two kids i did good in
life it got me i did i was i was i don't
know i don't know
i did good in life you know i mean
you sound like you kind of got you kind
of like just fell into situations bro
that's what it sounds like is that i'm
here now like like one could be a
mistake but two two yeah the first one
wasn't i don't think it was really a
mistake i was in a relationship for a
little while
and when the child came i was
not didn't want it or i didn't want it
it was just like okay say about it i
mean like
all right i'm not gonna tell her to get
rid of it that's my first shoot my
second you i'm already like bro i
already got one already like loudest no
no we're not even going there do you
know what i mean and i'll tell you like
there's deeper stories to how
like my second daughter as beautiful as
she is on earth like why she's here but
that one was pressure that second one do
you think you struggled with
responsibility because i know it's a lot
of us are like the struggle with the day
in day out you know having to provide
look after the emotional needs i mean i
mean like i i genuinely think it's it's
mostly on the girl if you get pregnant
because
i mean we have so many forms of birth
control that men don't have the access
to but like two
oh yeah i mean
it's not readily available at this point
so on her side if she wants to have the
baby then there's nothing stopping her
how is your how is your relationship
with these two women is it a good
relationship what now
yeah i have no i have to make it good
now would you mean you have to make it
good in terms of what i was saying
before in terms of like when a dad has
has to know that i have to sacrifice
um my like um
sanity and
well-being and feeling nice and feeling
good to accommodate their
like emotional
these needs if you go i mean like i'm
trying to say in the most like so raw
way as well man wanted to save illusions
that's what he wanted to say like you
know i mean like i have to be i have to
be like take a lot of stuff
in order for it to work and be cordial
so i was having this conversation
yesterday right um
we're men right and as men
we
we take we don't take well to violations
right so if i violated you i violated
you it could end in a physical
altercation
i'm saying
mothers of children
repeatedly violate yeah the fathers of
their children
and there's and as a man you've got to
take it you've got to find a way in
which to get violated a lot of the time
right and just roll with it and next
week
you're talking about this child's school
uniform yeah as if last week never
happened and you never got violated by
this individual last week and and i said
that is a lot on a lot of men's mental
health when it comes to um having the
wrong
baby mother because if i because i'm now
looking at you like i literally want to
argue if you have some kind of auto but
i can't because there's a child involved
and i'm looking at you and i'm saying
and you're like all right so next week
someone says i was going to school and
and you're like
did last week not happen like did did
you not like do you not remember what
you said or what you done i had a
therapy for that this is just taking
over